[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs comme chaque jeudi
l'essentiel des informations pour passer
un bon week-end dans les yvelines et
tout de suite le sommaire de cette
semaine place aux nouveaux karts
universal circuit est passé à
l'électrique 22 véhicules vous attention
dabiste est l'un de nos journalistes à
tester ses nouveaux bolides passionné de
cyclisme et curieux sont attendus au
vélodrome nationale le site accueille ce
week-end la deuxième édition du gala
star en piste des animations sont
programmées en présence de
professionnels et de la piste et de la
route
et bien sûr comme chaque semaine
l'agenda complet de vos sorties au
programme du cinéma des jeux et du
bien-être
c'est une première en ile-de-france un
circuit a mis en service cette année des
karting électrique pour remplacer ses
anciens véhicules thermiques objectif
réduire la consommation d'énergie tout
en gardons la performance de ces mini
voitures de course et notre journaliste
michael et demi d'euros s'est rendu sur
place pour les tester
[Musique]
c'est une première en ile de france un
centre propose de tester le karting
électrique à mes côtés emmanuel emmanuel
qui est propriétaire du centre pourquoi
avoir voulu tester le karting électrique
bonjour alors testé le kart électrique
parce que je pense que tout le monde
pense un peu électriques actuels à venir
pour moi ça ne l'est
c'est peut-être arrivé un petit peu tôt
puisque n'est effectivement unique en
ile de france
mais il fallait bien que quelqu'un fasse
le pari donc je les fais certains se
plaindront peut-être de ne plus hors de
bruit ni d'odeur mais on constate quand
même qu'il ya pas mal de personnes qui
adhèrent à cette nouvelle solution
quels sont les principaux changements en
termes de sensations de temps c'est la
notion d' accélération qui est plus plus
important que sur un kart thermique et
on a maintenant de la vitesse linéaire
jusqu'en bout ligne droite
hyper intéressante bon je pense qu'on
peut se lancer
on va tester le karting électrique
[Musique]
non
première sensation ben c'est pas trop
mal on voit pas trop la différence avec
un karting classique sauf peut-être à la
réaccélération et dans les virages il
faut vraiment vraiment faire attention
au frein parce qu'on peut vite déraper
[Musique]
merci beaucoup pour cette session parce
que ça coûte cher ou pas un circuit
comme celui là et des kartings comme
cela alors un quart thermique va coûter
environ un peu moins de 6000 euros hors
taxes un kart électrique va coûter plus
de 15000 euros hors taxes on peut rouler
à partir de 12 euros
lorsqu'on a une carte club merci
beaucoup et je crois que je vais
reprendre quelques cours quand même je
vais revenir ici sur ce circuit pour
m'entraîner
[Musique]
des animations et des stars ce samedi 16
novembre le gala star en piste revient
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
une après-midi une soirée autour du
cyclisme pour en parler avec nous les
organisateurs guy dauphin aimé closier
bonjour à tous les deux jours alors guy
dauphin vous lancez le challenge assure
osé lancer le monde ont aussi acquis qui
se raccroche au gala en 2017 avec votre
frère 1 pourquoi imaginer un rendez vous
de ce type on a organisé ce premier
challenge en 2017 qui regroupait des
cyclosportives sur toute la france
nous avions neuf épreuves c'est un moyen
de communication pour nous aujourd'hui
il ya 22 22 des prêts sur toute la
france
et ça c'est à dévier après sur le gala
en fait nous avions la chance de
bénéficier du b du vélodrome nationale
sites olympiques ou pas le rappeler sur
cette exaltante pour la remise des prix
du challenge et avec un comité restreint
de copains on s'est dit mais pourquoi
pas utiliser ce vélodrome pour faire
plus d'où l'idée est elle est venue de
faire ce gala sera en piste
en regroupant des pro routes mais pro
piste et surtout tout autant tout au
long de la journée de faire découvrir
cet anneau olympique exceptionnelle
puisque justement emery close et s'il
n'ya pas que les stars qui seront là le
public est accueilli il ya beaucoup
d'animations et de visites du vélodrome
notamment et tout ça oui oui donc
beaucoup d'animations autour de cet
événement avec des baptêmes fist et bmx
organisé tout durant tout l'après midi
une nouveauté aussi par rapport à
l'année dernière c'est le record de
l'heure
sous l'assistance respiratoire par
philippe pons et l'élection de miss vélo
france et puis effectivement des visites
aussi durant l'après midi en même temps
que les baptêmes et un village aussi
partenaires sur la centrale les
partenaires du gala star en piste c'est
l'idée aussi peut-être d'accompagner le
cycle et ça se pratique pas
nécessairement de n'importe comment
aussi d'une question de matériel pour
tout ce qui est baptême
tout est prêté par le vélodrome aussi
bien ce samedi que tout au long de
l'année c'est à dire que tout le monde
pour aller faire un baptême vous y allez
en short et un tennis et tout le
matériel est prêté
ça permet en fait toute cette journée de
mixer toutes les disciplines du vélo
parce que vous avez bmx qui est une
piste qui est vraiment réalisé pour ça
et vous avez la piste bien sur cet
anneau et on me l'a au mix de la route
et la piste en même temps donc on
regroupe quasiment que le vtt mais on
regroupe quasiment tous les pays du
touquet dynamique du vélo à quel moment
vous êtes dit on va associer les pros
finalement est-ce que le rendez vous il
est pour l'épreuve pour le public c'est
un petit peu des deux l'état d'esprit ce
qui a aussi de me refaire revivre un peu
l'esprit des six jours comme il y avait
un petit peu dans les années 80-90
modestement bien sûr parce que c'est
qu'une soirée
mais l'idée c'est ça c'est de refaire
revivre un peu les belles heures du vélo
et les belles heures du vélo savent sa
compagne par les pro routes par les pros
piste et puis bah pourquoi pas voir la
suite pourquoi le vtt ou le bmx mais
constante depuis tout à l'heure on dit
les pros les pros mais qui sont in her
quelques noms sur la piste il ya du nom
mathilde gros françois pervis quentin
lafargue la route on aille à aux anneaux
fredo tony gallopin situe à samuel
dumoulin qui viennent sans soucis
viennent c'est c'est vraiment un réel
plaisir de les voir venir de participer
en plus avec nous à l'organisation ce ne
sont pas juste un acteur puisqu'il joue
jeux sur les réseaux et du dernier
conseil pour qu'on puisse faire de cette
soirée en fait vraiment une fête c'est
vraiment l'esprit de galles à dire que
tout le monde joue monde va venir avec
un esprit bon enfant
il y aura un vrai partage avec le public
bien que tout le monde peut accéder ou
prou ce soir là c'est vraiment l'esprit
du critérium après les tours de france
du tour de france s'est toujours des
critériums et
c'est le moment ils sont plus
accessibles en fait exactement et là
vous avez y sont là pendant trois heures
il ya toute une série d'enchaînements
des preuves mais ils sont vraiment placé
au milieu de la centrale pour justement
être accessible par les publics par les
enfants par les bars par tout le monde
en fait l'an dernier 1500 personnes
avaient répondu présentes
est-ce que vous visitez le même chiffre
cette année plus haut oui et on vise
beaucoup plus haut et on peut déjà dire
qu'on est plus de 3500 personnes
inscrits ce jour donc il reste encore de
la place
il y aura une billetterie sur place
aussi pour les personnes qui souhaitent
venir
mais oui on a déjà dépassé largement le
quota de l'année dernière et pour les
fans l'occasion de repartir avec un bel
autographes d'un champion du monde ou
d'un champion d'europe merci à tous les
deux d'être revenue sur le plateau alors
le gars la star en piste débute à 13h au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
un petit mot de culture à présent et au
début de cette page culturelle avec
d'autres rendez vous cinéma cette
semaine patrick jacques de dixmude est
allé à la rencontre de marc album grave
s de directeur de l'ugc skywest
bonjour à tous bienvenue à ugc
skywest donc la semaine prochaine vous
allez retrouver deux grands films le
premier c'est le nouveau roman polanski
j'accuse du titre éponyme avait créé par
in usa l'art en 1898 emmenés par
notamment aux jean dujardin messieurs et
milito là quelqu'un doit exposer toute
l'histoire en tant qu'officier d'actifs
je ne peux rien écrire là dessus
le bourg non
- si vous retrouverez aussi également le
prochain nom 66 avec matt damon et
christian bale qui va retracer la course
mythique du mans en 1966 la rivalité
entre ford et ferrari nous assez les
deux grandes nouveautés de la semaine
prochaine je vous engage aussi à les
réserver vos places très rapidement pour
la reine des neiges pour tous ceux qui
ont des enfants
naturellement cette date est très
importante le film sort le 20 novembre
prochain
et aussi vous pourrez participer à une
avant première le 6 décembre pour le
film docteur emmenée par michel blanc et
pour terminer vous avez aussi une grande
un grand film la fin d'une trilogie
très attendu le 18 décembre prochain et
vous pouvez dès maintenant réserver vos
places avec la dernière partie de la
trilogie de star wars
[Musique]
quelques rendez-vous à gravure saint
quentin en yvelines propose une nouvelle
carte blanche c'est chantal rooney qui
expose cette fois au coeur de l'atelier
situé à elancourt ses oeuvres gravées
sont à découvrir jusqu'au 28 novembre un
vernissage est organisé ce dimanche 17
novembre à 11 heures et un peu de
bien-être à présent la médiathèque
antoine de saint-exupéry à voisins le
bretonneux vous propose des conférences
et des ateliers cinq dates sont
organisées avec l'association
iny montaigne équilibre énergie au
programme de la sophrologie du
stretching postural de l'hypnose la
première débute ce samedi 16 novembre
cette année le thème est plus orienté
vers la confiance en soi
donc comme l'a notamment la date de
février et celle d'avril qui sera un peu
plus orienté pour les adolescents ou ou
jeunes adultes qui ont des examens des
concours à passer ce sera la période
donc mais pas que les adultes pourront
aussi venir venir découvrir c'est
pratique
nous en parlions avec notre invité la
semaine dernière jusqu'au 23 novembre ce
sont les lui d'idées et à saint quentin
en yvelines
ce week-end un deuxième temps fort est
organisé cet avis pr cette fois ça se
déroule au gymnase alain mimoun les 16
et 17 novembre 18 heures de jeu on
entrée libre
et l'entrée est gratuite c'est la
cinquième édition du festi jeu de
villepreux sur ces deux jours avec un
espace jeux de société jeux vidéo
espaces ludiques pour les plus petits la
cinquième édition et
et on l'a c'est un événement qui réunit
beaucoup beaucoup de public
[Musique]
ce sont des mammifères bien mystérieux
les cétacés garde encore pour eux
plusieurs secret l'aquarium tropical du
palais de la porte dorée dévoile
quelques secrets de quatre espèces nos
confrères de via grand paris vous font
découvrir l'exposition
plongée au coeur des océans avec
baleineau police le nouveau rendez vous
de l'aquarium tropical de paris et
partez à la découverte de ses habitants
l'exposition s'intéresse à quatre
espèces de cétacés la baleine à bosse
lorque le cachalot et le dauphin elle
propose pour comprendre leur mode de vie
un éclairage scientifique et pour mettre
en lumière l'univers méconnu des cétacés
baleineau police et vous ludique et
pédagogique
c'est une exposition basée sur
l'information scientifique mais on les
présente de façon ludique et pour
chacune des espèces on détaille les
sociétés ont des tailles
pourquoi ils sont ensemble comment ils
sont ensemble on va être immergé dans
les océans au contact des cétacés on a
des vidéos spectaculaires qui nous ont
été prêtés des très belles photos on a
dû sauver les pouvoir écouter des chants
de baleines à bosse vous allez pouvoir
rentrer intérieur des océans et puis
vous allez découvrir plein de choses que
les cétacés fonds au cours de leur
société de leur groupe
la dernière partie de l'exposition est
consacrée à la préservation de ces
espèces et de leur milieu de vie
un enjeu qui se reflète également dans
la scénographie immersive
elle a été faite à l'image de notre
planète ces studios gang qui s'en est
occupé
et ils nous ont proposé de réaliser la
terre en fait ce que vous voyez ici là
ce sont les 30 % de notre planète et
vous êtes dans 70% des océans dans 30%
de la surface de cette salle correspond
à la terre et 70% aux océans est donc là
vous êtes dans baleineau paul ismaël lô
police et la cité des baleines et donc
les océans le public est amené à se
déplacer dans les océans autour de cette
terre et la terre est en carton parce
qu'elle est extrêmement fragile d'accord
elle va subir des effets des impacts des
activités humaines donc nous en
l'occurrence et donc elle va être amené
à se dégrader plus facilement la terre
est très fragile donc elle est en carton
baleineau police et a retrouvé à
l'aquarium tropical de paris jusqu'au 21
juin 2020 c'est la fin du set 8 loisirs
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour de nouveaux
rendez vous
[Musique]
on